acheter le pain ou les croissants le
dimanche matin tu pas vraiment une
partie de plaisir pour les habitants de
charmoy cette petite commune du centre
l'yonne est traversé par la d 6 106
l'une des routes les plus fréquentées et
les plus accidentogènes du département
il ya beaucoup de circulation de plus en
plus énormément de camions de gens qui
respectent pas les limitations
on va dire que oui il ya un énorme
trafic ça fait qu'elle est très
dangereuse et rend beaucoup d'heureux
des voitures aux heures de pointe de
quoi on va dire ça peut s'expliquer
aussi des cas soit 6 accidentogènes que
ça c'est que traverse quand même le du
nord au sud du département c'est la
route principale du département comme ex
nationale si cela des 606 traverse une
zone du nord au sud
depuis pau sur yonne jusqu à avallon via
les principales villes du département
chaque jour plus de douze mille
véhicules participent à ce rond point
cet axe routier très fréquenté est aussi
l'un des plus dangereux
l'an dernier plus de 27000 excès de
vitesse ils ont été relevées cette
semaine cette route encore été le
théâtre de deux accidents mortels
la gendarmerie a décidé de multiplier
les contrôles elles viennent de
l'annoncer sur les réseaux sociaux et
veut taper fort quand il ya du bleu
comme on dit au bord de la route les
gens ralentissent et donc on va bleuir
les départementales 606 de 6 heures du
matin à 20 heures le soir les quatre
unités de l'escadron départemental de
sécurité routière sont concernés et ce
sera a minima 22 gendarmes pleine
période de départs en vacances
les contrôles vont donc s'accentuer sur
la d6 106 une répression accrue visible
et assumée par les forces de l'ordre
depuis le début de l'année vingt
personnes ont trouvé la mort sur les
routes de l'yonne